hi I wanted to take a minute to thank
the commenters who agreed with my my
latest rant about how the eleventh
incarnation of Doctor Who is far too
touchy-feely as for the rest of you the
other 99.9% who disagreed with me I'd
like to clarify a few things
first of all I was really surprised by
the level of vitriol even considering
how important this topic is darn AK
letter bomb writes if I tried to
describe how much I hate you it would be
like determining the exact number of
atoms in the entire universe yeah well
you know who could determine the exact
number of atoms in the entire universe
the fourth of the fifth incarnation of
the doctor because they were a little
more together than this latest version
it's ginger 37 writes I respected your
opinion at first because you're entitled
to it but then you had to diss bowties
that was a common refrain in the
comments little monkey bro 101 wrote
bowties are cooler than scarfs and so
are fezzes look there's only two classes
of people that can get away with wearing
bowties and scarfs one of them is 80
year old Shriners from the Midwest the
other is 20 year old hipster dudes from
Brooklyn nine hundred year old aliens
should know better
Stargate six one two six three three Oh
wrote how dare you the doctor is
different each time he regenerates well
duh look what bothers me is all the
touchy-feely huggy buggy timey wimey
wibbly-wobbly stuff they have going on
in these latest episodes Rodney McKay
writes if you don't like this version of
Doctor Who request the BBC to change his
name to dr. Phil Touche
right on Rodney you're my kind of guy I
command my fanboy minions to lobby the
BBC to do what Rodney said let's change
the name of the show to dr. Phil on a
totally unrelated note awesome McNinja
writes if he says one thing about
bronies oh don't tempt me awesome
McNinja don't tempt me
there's a lot of stuff I'm angry about
what's getting under your skin make a
video and let me know everyone's got an
angry nerd in them